سويسرا عرفتها سمح باعاده تصدير 96 دبابه
من طراز واحد نحو اوكرانيا قائله ان ذلك
يخالف قوانينها وسياسه الحياد التي تتبعها
ياتي ذلك في وقت ناقش فيه قاده الاتحاد
الاوروبي ضمانات لدعم عسكري طويل الاجل
وذلك تزامنا تزامنا مع رفض نتنياهو الماده
واشنطن اوكرانيا بمنظومه القبه الحديديه
اهلا بكم كندا خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه
ثلاثه مسارات في اي سياق يندرج خطاب
الضمانات طويله الاجل للدعم الاوروبي
والعسكري لاوكرانيا في ضوء ما وصل اليه
الموقفان العسكري والدبلوماسي في الحرب
الدائره باوكرانيا وكيف تبدو خارطه
المواقف الاوروبيه من هذا التوجه ولماذا
تتحفظ سويسرا على هذه الحزمه وترفض مبدا
اوكرانيا باسلحه النوعيه كدبابات وهل يمثل
موقفها تصدعا في الموقف الاوروبي من الامر
اي تاثير للتحفظات السويسريه والدنماركيه
والاسرائيليه على مد اوكرانيا باسلحه
نوعيه على بشريات الحرب وايضا تداعياتها
على السعي الاوروبي لاحداث توازن قوي في
الموقف منها حتى تجاه الدعم الامريكي
لكياف
[موسيقى]
في حرب لا تلوح وفي افقها نهايه قريبه
سواء بالحسم العسكري او التسويه السياسيه
تتحول كلفه دعم طرف في مواجهه الطرف الاخر
الى عبء يثير المواقف المتباينه حتى داخل
المعسكر الواحد هكذا هو الموقف داخل البيت
الاوروبي الذي تداعى قادته الى مناقشه
حزمه ضمانات بشان دعم عسكري ومساعدات
متنوعه في مواجهه موسكو دعم تلتفوا حوله
اغلبيه لكنه لا يحوز الاجماع الكامل فها
هو المجلس الفيدرالي السويسري يرفض اعاده
تصدير بالكامل لاسلحه سويسريه الصنع نحو
اوكرانيا مخالفه للقوانين السويسريه
الحاليه التي تمنع ذلك النوع من التصدير
نحو بلد يخوض نزاعا دوليا المجلس اضاف ان
مثل ذلك الدعم العسكري يغير من سياسه
الذي تنتهجه الدوله السويسريه تحتاج بار
وقتا وقرارات حتى تقتنع بوجهه نظر الاتحاد
الاوروبي الذي قال بيان له ان دعم العسكري
الموجه لاوكرانيا ضروري لمواجهه ما وصفه
باعمال العدوان الروسي وجهود موسكو لزعزعه
الاستقرار في المنطقه ليس الاتحاد
الاوروبي وحده من يواجه هذا الجدل واشنطن
هي الاخرى تجد نفسها قباله موقف برئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه
قال فيه ان تل ابيب ترفض وبوضوح تسليم
الولايات المتحده اوكرانيا منظومه القبه
الحديديه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من جيمس
موران المستشار السابق لدى الاتحاد
الاوروبي
وينضم الينا من جناز الدكتور
الكسندر
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه ومن
عمان لوفي تدويريا الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي اهلا بكم جميعا الى هذه
الحلقه وابدا معك في عمان فايز الدويري لو
بدانا بوجهه نظر ميدانيه وعسكريه بحته
ماذا تقرا في فحوى هذه الضمانات وما مدى
اهميتها وما هي دلالاتها الان
يعني هذه الضمانات هي
الورق الرئيسيه بيد الغرب لماذا لانه كما
يقال الضربه التي لا تقسم الظهر تقويه
فبعد هذا الدعم وبعد هذا التكتل والتوحد
خلف اوكرانيا لن يقبل الغرب وامريكا
تحديدا وبريطانيا بانتصار روسي لماذا لان
هذا سيغير في المعادلات الدوليه
التصريفات الروسيه الامريكيه لروسيا لا
اود ان اذهب الى التصريحات المتطرفه لكن
كانوا يعتبروها كانها دوله عظمى اقليميه
وليس جلوبال الان اي هزيمه لاوكرانيا
ستعتبر هزيمه للغرب وهذه ستقوي من الدوري
الروسي وبالتالي ستتعدد الاقطاب الدوليه
سيكون هناك الصين كقوه اقتصاديه وقوه
عسكريه صاعده روسيا كقوه منتصره في مواجهه
الغرب وهناك ثنائيه او تقارب كبير ما بين
المواقف الصيني والروسيه وبالتالي نحن
نريد قراءه ميدانيه عسكريه لهذا الامر
القراءه الميدانيه الان هناك عمليه تصعيد
مستمر في التزويد الغربي اذا عدنا الى
بدايات الحرب كان هناك الحديث عن اسلحه
متوسطه وخفيفه وصواريخ قصيره المدى لا
تتعدى
ولكن بدا الحديث
والمواقف الغربيه تتصاعد مع اشتداد
المعارك واطاله اعمدها ذهبوا الى منظومات
الدفاع الجوي حتى وصلت الى الباتريوت
ذهبوا الى التزويد بالدبابات حتى وصلت الى
ابرامز ذهبوا الى التجويد بالصواريخ حتى
الان هناك موافقه امريكيه على صواريخ
اتكامس مسافه 300 كيلو متر اي بمدى ظل
العاصفه هناك حديث عن طائرات اف 16 اذا
التصعيد الغربي في التزويد بالسلاح هو
يتماشى مع متطلبات المعركه كلما ازدادت
المتطلبات
ساقتبس منك هذه الجمله لاتحول الى جيمس
موران هذا التصعيد الغربي بتزويد اوكرانيا
بالمزيد من السلاح وهذه القرارات ما
جدواها الان في ظل الوضع الاقتصادي الصعب
الذي والسياسي الذي تعيشه الدول الاوروبيه
ودول الاتحاد الاوروبية جمالا
تجهيزات الاسلحه او مساعدات الاخرى الى
اوكرانيا وصلت 77 مليار يورو
مقدمه من المؤسسات والدول الاعضاء
الاوروبيه
وهذا الرقم سيزداد اكثر من ذلك وهم
يجتمعون حاليا في هذه الساعه وفي بروكسل
في المجلس الاوروبي لتقديم المزيد من
الالتزامات لمساعدته اوكرانيا ومن المهم
ان نتذكر بان السلاح الجديد دبابات العاب
الوصول باعداد كبيره
وهذا ليس التصعيد هذا مجرد دفاع دفاع صرف
ضد الغزوه الروسي ولابد ان يعتبر ذلك بهذا
الشكل وبعد هذه التجهيزات عم تصل سن كيف
سيكون الوضع على الارض
في اوكرانيا ولكن
التضامن الغربي خصم اتحاد الاوروبي سيبقى
قويا على الارجح
الشعوب الاوروبيه عانت في السنه الماضيه
من اجراءات التضخم المالي والاخرى ولكن
ليس هناك اي مؤشر ان الراي العام الاوروبي
قد تغيره فهم جميعا دائما يؤيدون تقديم
المزيد مساعدات لاوكرانيا لمواجهه هذا
الغزو الروسي
لماذا
السويسرا او بيرن لا تقتنع حتى الان لم
تقتنع بهذا الكلام
في الحقيقه انا لا اعرف كيفيه الاجابه عن
هذا السؤال المفتوح ولكن في الايام الاولى
من الاجتياح الروسي لاوكرانيا الحكومه
السويسريه
بتعبير من عدد كبير من الوزراء قاموا
بادانه هذا الاعتداء الروسي الذي يستهدف
اوكرانيا وعادوا التذكير بان سويسرا
ملتزمه بالنظام العالمي القانوني ومبدا
عدم الاعتداء على دوله ذات سياده هي ضد
استخدام القوه
اعذرني على المقاطعه لكن هذا موقف سياسي
ودول كثيره في العالم اعلنت نفس هذا
الموقف ولكن عسكريا لماذا ترفض
الانخراط مع باقي الدول الاوروبيه في
عمليه دعم كييف عسكريا بالسلاح
لو سمحتي لي بان اكمل الاجابه يمكنني ان
اقول ان سويسرا
ساهمت وقدمت مساهمات على المستوى الانساني
بالاضافه الى استضافه اللاجئين بسبب هذا
النزاع وسويسرا ملتزمه بحل سلمي لهذا
النزاع اود ان اذكر المشاهدين الكرام بان
سويسرا ليست دوله عضو في حلف شمال الاطلسي
وليست دوله عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي
سويسرا هي دوله محايده وهي بالتالي تلتزم
بمبدا الحياه ولذلك عبرت عن هذا الموقف
الذي يقضي بمنع بيع الاسلحه لدول تشهد
نزار سيد جيمس يعني كون صحيح ان سويسرا
ليست عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن هذا
الكلام الذي يقوله الان الكسن من ان
الحياد السويسري ربما يمنحها من ان تنخرط
فيه عمليه تزويد اكياس بالسلاح هل هو مقنع
بالنسبه لكم انتم كاروبيين بالنسبه للدول
الاوروبيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اعتقد ان سويسرا لديها ومنذ زمن طويل جدا
الدوله حياتيه واغواعد كل اوروبا تحترم
ذلك وفعلا سويسرا تلعب دورا كما قال الضيف
الاخر في تقديم مساعدات انسانيه وهي مركز
الصليب الاحمر وهو تتعب دورا كبيرا في
جانب الانساني في هذا الحرب وحروب اخرى في
العالم ولا اعتقد لاي شخص في اوروبا يتوقع
من سويسرا ان تشارك بعسكريه باي طريقه
كانت نظرا للسجل لها السابق وايضا نظرا
لانها دوله حياديه
وكل الدول تحترم هذه الحياه
لو تحدثنا بلغه الحسابات العسكريه
الميدانيه هذا النقاش السويسري الاوروبي
هل ترى ان له ربما انعكاسات ميدانيه هل
عدم مثلا ارسال
الطائرات او دبابات عفوا واحد يشكل ثغره
في جدار الدعم العسكري الاوروبي لكييف
لاوكرانيا
اعتقد اعتقد ان الحسابات الغربيه لا تراهن
كثيرا على موافقه السويسريه لان سويسرا
بدا الحياد 1515 واصبحت
قانون في 1815 ولم تشترك لا في الحرب
الاولى ولا في الحرب الثانيه وبالتالي لا
اتوقع ان الغرب كان يعول كثيرا على موقف
السويسري وبالتالي هذا الرقم من الدبابات
نعم يحدث فارق ولكن لم يكن اعتقد لم يكن
في الحسابات الغربيه الجاده وبالتالي
الحسابات الغربيه الجاده تاتي من الدول
الرئيسيه ومن الدول التي لها مواقف حاده
الدول الرئيسيه الدعم الامريكي البريطاني
الفرنسي الالماني الايطالي الدول ذات
المواقف المتجدده بولندا
هذه الدول بصوره عامه هي التي تقدم الجهد
الرئيسي من حيث المنظومات
العسكريه التي تحتاجها اله الحرب وبالتالي
نجد المانيا كانت ترفض بالمطلق وكانت
تتحدث عن نقص في المخزونات التي يحتاجها
جيش الالماني ثم وافقت وارسلت بطاريه
وارسلت الدبابات وغير ذلك اذا دعيني اقول
نعم في حال توفر هذا الرقم سيحدث فارقا
ميدانيا لكن لم يكن اعتقد في من ضمن
الحسابات الجاده وبالتالي هناك مقاربه
اخرى من الدول الداعمه بدءا من امريكا حتى
وصولا الى اصغر دوله وبالتالي اؤكد الغرب
لن يسمح اذا استطاع ان تنهزم اوكرانيا
وتنتصر روسيا لماذا لانه سيحدث تغيرات جيو
استراتيجيه الغرب لن يسمح بها لذا هو اصبح
ملزما ان يقدم الدعم الذي تحتاجه اوكرانيا
من اجل الاهداف سواء كانت بصوره كليه او
بصوره جزئيه تقود الى مخرج سياسي
سيد الكسندر
طبعا ليست سويسرا فقط هناك سويسرا هناك
الدنمارك هناك ايضا
الموقف الاسرائيلي الرافض لامداد السلاح
وقد عبر عن ذلك بنيامين نتنياهو عن هذا
الموقف ابلغ واشنطن بذلك كل هذا هل يصنع
فرق في معادله دعم كياف في الحرب على في
حربها في
وجه روسيا
موقف اسرائيل هو موقف مثير للاهتمام وهو
موقف مهم ولكن عوضا عن التركيز على قرار
تزويت اوكرانيا او عدم تزويد اوكرانيا
باسلحه
جو ارض
والقبة الحديديه يجب ان ننظر الى السياق
العام في بدايه الحرب قالت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه انها لا تود ان تنخرط وتشارك
في هذا النزاع لاحقا ولربما بعد عدد من
الضغوط ولكن ايضا بناء على القرارات
السياسيه الاسرائيليه قررت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه لان تقدم مساعدات بما في ذلك
المعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا واعتقد ان هذه الخطوه هي في
غايه الاهميه وبالتالي القرار لربما
يمكننا ان ناخذه فقط بالسياق الحالي
بالنسبه الى منظومه القبه الحديديه على اي
حال نحن نعرف ان هناك مناقشات متعدده في
هذه المرحله بالنسبه الى تزويد اوكرانيا
بدبابات واسلحه للمشاه ومدرعات وبالاضافه
الى ذلك التكنولوجيات الاسرائيليه التي
تقدم من المانيا ولكل هذه الاسباب اسرائيل
هي دوله صديقه
لاوكرانيا حيث انها تساهم على المستوى
العسكري بدعم اوكرانيا
هذا الموقف الذي تحدث عنه الان الكسندر
باترافير وهو تحفظ اسرائيل
بقوه بالرفض ان تمد رفضت اسرائيل ان تمد
واشنطن كييف بمنظومه القبه الحديديه اما
الاعتبارات والهواجس التي صنعت هذا الموقف
برايك
هل سمعتني
كنا نتحدث عن نعم تفضل
عن الهواجس التي ادت الى هذا الموقف
الاسرائيلي الرافض لتزويد اكياف بمنظومه
القبه الحديديه
طيب نحول نفس السؤال اللي هوري تفضل
يعني هناك عده اسباب هناك السبب الرئيسي
وهو الوضع في سوريا والوجود الروسي في
سوريا
وللعلم التوصيه التي قدمت لعدم تزويد
القبه اوكرانيا بالقبه الحديديه كانت من
الجانب العسكري والجانب الامني الاسرائيلي
لماذا لانه كانت تخوف ان تقوم روسيا
بتفعيل منظومه اس 300 التي زودتها الى
سوريا قبل اكثر من عام ونصف ولكنها لم
تسمح للاطقم السوريه بعد بتفعيل هذه
المنظومه وبالتالي كان هناك تخوف بان سيتم
نقل صلاحيه تفعيل عمل منظومه اس 300 سيكون
بيد او القرار سوري هذا النقطه رقم واحد
النقطه رقم اثنين
القبه الحديديه تعمل ضد الصواريخ قصيره
المدى من والمدافع من 5 كيلو الى 75 كيلو
تقنيا وجهه النظر انها لا تلائم مسرح
العمليات الاوكراني الذي تبلغ مساحته 630
الف كيلو متر مربع
هناك كذلك خوف وهاجس ان عمليه
تدميره وارده لان هناك سيطره جويه روسيه
امكانيه ان تسيطر او ان تستولي على جزئيه
معينه من القبه الحديديه والوصول الى
الاسرار العسكريه وبالتالي نقلها الى
ايران العدو اللدود الذي يهدد اسرائيل
وبالتالي الموقف الامريكي تفهم ذلك وطلب
من من الجانب الاسرائيلي ان تساعد
اوكرانيا من خلال العمل الاستخباري اولا
وان تدرب الكوادر القادره على تطوير
منظومه انذار مبكر ثانيا من اجل تلافي
الاسباب التي الثلاث التي ذكرتها جنس
موران ما هي خطه الاوروبيين لحسم خياراتهم
الاستراتيجيه على هذا الصعيد برايك
مستوى العسكريات سنشاهد استمرار للمساعدات
الكبيره المقدمه لاوكرانيا في الاشهر
القادمه واعتقد ان ذلك سوف يؤدي الى خلقه
فرق كبير فالكثير من المحللين هنا في
النيتو وفي اتحاد الاوروبي يشير الى
انتصارات سوف تتحقق في المستقبل بفضل
الاسلحه الجديده التعهد بها في بدايه
السنه اضافه الى طائرات اف 16 التي
نتوقع تحقيق تقدم في الشهر الخريف القادم
ان هذا سي لا نعرف وكالجانب اخر هناك ايضا
الموضوع الذي يناقش حاليا هنا في بروكسل
من قبل قاده الاوروبيين حول اعاده بناءها
عماره
400 مليار دولار
من سيدفع الثمن ذلك والسؤال هل الارنب هو
اموال المجمده الروسيه بموجب العقوبات
المفروض من اوروبا ولايه المتحده وغيرها
هل هذه الاموال ستستخدم لاعاده اوكرانيا
وهذا طبعا نقاش معقد جدا ولا اعتقد اي شيء
ملموس يظهر من ذلك اليوم ولكن سيواصل ذلك
كل ذلك جزء من احجيه التي يتعلق باعاده
اوكرانيا الى وضعها السابق مع ان تنتهي
هذه الحرب الماساويه شكرا جزيلا لكم
جيمس موران مستشار سابق لدائره العمل
الخارجي للاتحاد الاوروبي كنت معنا من
بروكسل وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا الكسندر بوتر
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه كنت
معنا من جناف وشكرا لفيصل دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من عمان
شكرا لكم جميعا
وبهذا ناتي الى ختام هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]